extends beyond our individual and
personal reach it would seem ridiculous
to dispute invitations of the founders
or the greatest generation on the basis
of a lack of membership in either group
we recognize our lineage as a
generational trust as inheritance and
the real dilemma posed by reparations is
just that a dilemma of inheritance it is
impossible to imagine America without
the inheritance of slavery as historian
ed Baptist is written enslavement quote
shaped every crucial aspect of the
economy and politics of America so that
by 1836 more than 600 million almost
half of the economic activity in the
United States derived directly or
indirectly from the cotton produced by
the million odd slaves by the time the
enslaved were emancipated they comprised
the largest single asset in America
three billion in 1860 dollars more than
all the other assets in the country
combined the method of cultivating this
asset was neither gentle cajoling nor
persuasion but torture rape and child
trafficking enslavement reigned for 250
years on these shores when it ended this
country could have extended its hallowed
principles life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness to all regardless of color
but America had other principles in mind
and so forth century after the Civil War
black people were subjected to a
relentless campaign of terror
a campaign that extended well into the
lifetime of majority leader McConnell it
is tempting to divorce this modern
campaign of terror of plunder from
enslavement but the logic of enslavement
of white supremacy respects no such
borders and the god of bondage was
lustful and began Meniere's coup d'etats
and convict leasing vagrancy laws and
debt peonage
redlining and racist GI bills poll taxes
and state state-sponsored terrorism we
grant that mr. McConnell was not alive
for Appomattox but he was
life or the electrocution of George
Stinney he was alive for the blinding of
Isaac Woodward he was alive to witness
khakhra see in his native Alabama and a
regime premise on electoral theft
Majority Leader McConnell cited civil
rights legislation yesterday as well he
should because he was alive to witness
the harassment jailing and betrayal of
those responsible for that legislation
by a government sworn to protect them he
was alive for the red lining of Chicago
and the looting of black homeowners of
some four billion dollars victims of
that plunder are very much alive today I
am sure they'd love a word with the
Majority Leader what they know what this
committee must know is that while
emancipation dead-bolted the door
against the bandits of America Jim Crow
wedged the windows wide open and that is
the thing about Senator McConnell's
something it was 150 years ago and it
was right now the typical black family
in this country has 1/10 the wealth of
the typical white family black women
died in childbirth they're four times
the rate of white women and there is of
course the shame of this land of the
free boasting the largest prison
population on the planet of which the
descendants of the enslaved make up the
largest share the matter of reparations
is one of making amends and direct
address but it is also a question of
citizenship in HR 40 this body has a
chance to both make good on its 2009
apology for enslavement and reject
fair-weather patriotism to say that a
nation is both its credits and it's
debits that if Thomas Jefferson matters
so to Sally Hemings that if d-day
matters so does black Wall Street that
if Valley Forge matters so does Fort
Pillow because the question really is
not whether we will be tied to the
something's of our past but whether we
are courageous enough to be tied to the
hold of them thank you
Thank You mr. Coates next witnesses